>> Dana: A BIG DREAM FOR GEN Z
IS TO SELL FAT TUB 18.
YOUNG AMERICANS SAY, DO YOU
BLAME US FOR WANTING TO GET
INSTA FAMOUS?
REVEALS A THIRD OF THEM ASPIRE
TO BE SOCIAL MEDIA INFLUENCERS
BUT WHEN ASKED WHAT A THIRD WAS,
NONE OF THEM COULD DO FRACTIONS.
HAVEN'T THEY HEARD THE GOOD NEWS
ABOUT FREE COLLEGE?
BUT IT GETS WORSE.
ABOUT A QUARTER OF THEM ADMIT
THAT BEING AN INFLUENCE OR IS
THERE ACTUAL PLAN ONCE THEY
FINISH SCHOOL.
APPARENTLY GEN Z YOU BOYS ARE
MORE LIKELY THAN GIRLS TO
BELIEVE THAT BEING IN INFLUENCER
IS THEIR ONLY CAREER OPTION.
IT'S NOT JUST FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
ANYMORE.
>> THIS IS DR. ANTHONY FOUND
CHEAP.
I'VE GOT A LOT OF TIME IN MY
HANDS.
I'M IN INFLUENCER.
I KNOW YOU LIKED MY INFLUENCE
WHEN I WAS RUINING YOUR
LIVELIHOODS.
AND NOW A SHOUT OUT TO MY POSSE,
THE BOOSTER CREW.
>> BOOSTER GAME!
>> THEY ARE NICE YOUNG PEOPLE
BUT THEY ARE UNVAXXED.
IF YOU COULD STAY 6 FEET APART,
I'D APPRECIATE IT.
A WORD FROM OUR SPONSOR.
IT'S THE WUHAN-B-DON, THE ONLY
ONE WET MARKET APPROVED.
I SHOULD'VE WORN A MASK!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Dana: JONATHAN, IF YOU
COULD DO IT ALL OVER AGAIN,
WOULD YOU BECOME IN INFLUENCER?
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT MEANS.
HONESTLY, LISTEN.
TO INFLUENCE FOR THE GOOD IS
ALWAYS A GOOD THING.
BUT YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
IT'S WORTHWHILE TO FOLLOW,
RIGHT?
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
A LOT OF THESE INFLUENCERS, THEY
ARE DOING THINGS THAT ARE REALLY
NOT WORTHWHILE FOLLOWING.
I THINK WE NEED A GENERATION OF
PEOPLE WILLING TO STAND UP
SAYING, I TELL MIKE IN ORDER TO
LEAD I'M GOING TO DO SOMETHING
THIS WORTHWHILE.
SOMETHING THAT'S GOOD.
SOMETHING THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
SOMETHING THAT'S HONEST.
SOMETHING THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
INFLUENCE PEOPLE TO FOLLOW AND
TO MAKE SACRIFICES, SACRIFICES
TO ATTAIN SOMETHING THAT'S
WORTHWHILE.
>> Dana: I DO NOT THINK GEN Z
IS THAT DEEP.
>> I CAN TRY SOMETHING ELSE!
>> Dana: I AGREE WITH YOU.
KAT, YOU ARE A BIT OF AN
INFLUENCER.
YOU'RE INFLUENCING PEOPLE WITH
YOUR COMEDY AND YOU ARE HERE ON
THE SHOW.
THE IDEA THAT YOUR JOB IS GOING
TO BE JUST INFLUENCING THEM,
THAT'S A CAREER OPTION?
>> ONE TIME I ATE SOUP ON
YOUTUBE LIVE.
I WAS LIKE, WHY AM I DOING THIS?
I STILL DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHY PEOPLE WATCH
THE EITHER, BUT YOU DID, YOU
WEIRDOS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A PURPOSE FOR
WANTING...
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO INFLUENCE?
YOU HAVE TO BE LIKE, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ME
AND I WANT TO HAVE A PLATFORM
FOR THIS REASON.
IF YOU JUST WANT TO HAVE A
PLATFORM SO YOU CAN JUST, YOU
KNOW, BE IN A BIKINI AND DANCE
AROUND?
THAT'S NOT REALLY SOMETHING TO
ASPIRE TO ESPECIALLY BECAUSE ONE
OF THE BEST FEELINGS IN THE
WORLD IS TO BE ON VACATION AND
BE ABLE TO LOOK UGLY.
THEY CAN'T DO THAT!
>> Dana: NOT WORRY ABOUT
CAMERAS.
LAWRENCE, DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
GETTING THE SENSE THAT COLLEGE
ISN'T WORTH IT?
>> YEAH.
AND I SUPPORT THEM ON THAT.
I ALSO DON'T REALLY THINK THAT
THEY REALLY WANT TO BE
INFLUENCED.
THE PART OF BEING AN INFLUENCER
IS HAVING THE INFLUENCE TO STAND
YOUR GROUND.
BUT THE FIRST MOMENT SOMEBODY
CRITICIZES YOU, IT BREAKS THEM.
THEY GET BROKEN SO QUICKLY.
I THINK THEY JUST WANT TO SELL
STUFF ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND MAKE A
LITTLE MONEY OFF OF IT.
AND JUST BE FAMOUS.
AND BE KNOWN FOR IT.
WHICH IS...
THERE IS A BUSINESS MODEL FOR
THAT, START A PRODUCT, GO OUT
THERE, MAKE THE MONEY ON YOUR
OWN.
IT'S JUST SAD.
I DO NOT THINK YOUNG PEOPLE
ACTUALLY REALIZE THEIR VALUE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM RIGHT THERE.
THEY DON'T REALIZE THEY CAN BE
SOMETHING MORE AND THIS IS THE
EASY WAY OUT.
IT'S KIND OF SAD FOR THEM.
>> Dana: IS THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA
IN ALASKA?
>> YEAH.
WE...
EVERYONE'S BIG INTO MY SPACE.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M GETTING TIRED OF
SOCIAL MEDIA.
I'M JUST...
THIS MAKES ME SAD, IT REALLY
DOES.
I JUST HAD TO UNFOLLOW A WOMAN
THIS AFTERNOON BECAUSE SHE
TURNED AROUND AND SAW ME.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
I DO GET APPROACHED SOMETIMES.
YOU KNOW.
ROGAINE ASKED ME TO DO
SOMETHING.
THE YARMULKE COMPANY...
THEY ASKED ME TO BE ON THE COVER
OF APPROVAL ALONE MAGAZINE."
"ALONE MAGAZINE."
AM I THE ONLY ONE WHEN I HEARD
GEN Z, I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT
MEANT?
AM I THE ONLY ONE?
WHY DON'T THEY MAKE IT...
CAN THEY COME UP WITH AN EASIER
WORD?
COULDN'T THEY JUST SAY IDIOTS?
[LAUGHTER]
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I'M
SORRY.
DON'T SEND ME ANGRY MESSAGES ON
TIKTOK.
I DON'T KNOW